okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and we have a bunch of questions saved
up that i didn't get to on other
uh sessions
and let's see where should we start
um
the question here
from looks like uh
ts
can i talk about turbulence
and why it's the greatest unsolved
problem of classical mechanics or at
least it might be taken to be that way
okay
so let's talk about turbulence what is
turbulence
sort of its full name is fluid
turbulence
here's here's the basic story let's say
that you
have
a stream of water
and you put your put your finger in the
stream of water
the water will flow around your finger
and the question is
what will the water do as it flows
around your finger clearly the water has
to you know kind of parts
around going around your finger
and then has to kind of rearrange itself
when it comes back behind your finger
if the water is flowing slowly it will
show what's called laminar flow kind of
flow in layers where essentially the
water comes in towards your finger or
let's imagine it's a slightly larger
object towards some um
cylinder you put it down into the water
um it uh and the the water kind of flows
smoothly around that cylinder it kind of
the water as it comes in towards the
cylinder it kind of parts goes round the
cylinder reforms behind the cylinder and
you'll see pictures if you put for
example ink in the water you'll see the
streamlines of where the water goes as
the as the ink
the ink is in the water and it's being
being carried with water you'll see it
kind of smoothly stream around the
cylinder so that's what happens if the
flow of the water is slow
if the flow of water gets faster several
things start to happen
what will happen at first is
behind the cylinder there will be well
first thing you'll see is that behind
the cylinder there'll be a couple of
eddies that form on the two sides of the
of the cylinder there'll be eddies where
the water is kind of um
kind of kind of swirling around behind
the cylinder two little that is behind
the cylinder same same thing if you put
a plate
in in water you'll see that around the
the two ends of the plate there'll be
two little eddies that form swirl around
as you make the flow of the water faster
you'll start breaking off
and the eddies break off in what's
called the vortex street
where first theory at the top will break
off then there the bottom will break off
and you'll see behind the the plate or
the cylinder you'll you'll see this kind
of uh
these these kind of um
offset
eddies just streaming back in the water
behind the behind the plates of the
cylinder so that's the next thing that
happens so what happens when you make
the water go even faster
well the eddies will start to break off
not uh in the the for
in the original vortex street they'll be
kind of like you know lamp posts on
opposite sides of the street that'll be
just a periodic array of vortices when
you make the flow faster the vortices
will start breaking off
not not periodically like that and
there'll be a couple of two vortices and
then there'll be nothing then there'll
be another clump of vortices and so on
and you'll start seeing interactions
between the vortices in the vortex
street
as behind the cylinder these vortices
will start
start interacting with each other
okay then what happens
um as you increase the the rate of flow
of the water even further you'll start
getting something much more random
behind the plate the water will seem to
be just sort of flowing around randomly
you'll make this wake behind the
cylinder and it'll look quite random
that's turbulence
and
the um
the phenomenon
that you see and it's a very generic
phenomenon in fluids
when sort of rates of flow are slow you
get this kind of laminar smoothly
sliding type type behavior when rates of
flow are high you get this random
turbulence forming okay there's a lot to
say about this and a fundamental
question is why do you get that kind of
randomness and fluids i've been
interested in this question for a long
time i think i kind of know the answers
now and the answers are quite
interesting
um so first thing to talk about a little
bit is is about
uh patterns of flow in fluids
so
the question is if you have
a fluid like water and you have an
object of a certain size and you have a
speed of flow of a certain amount
and then you have a much bigger object
and a different rate of flow how do the
patterns of flow compare depending on
the size of the object the rate of flow
the viscosity of the fluid that is the
um as you as you kind of put pressure on
the fluid how much will the fluid then
flow that's essentially the viscosity
how how um
if you have um something like syrup
syrup has a much higher viscosity it has
a a much greater tendency to resist
uh kind of uh motion in the fluid the
kind of characteristic form of a
viscosity is if you take um two plates
and you put fluid in between them and
you try and start moving one of the
plates
how much force does it take to move that
plate if the fluid is very unviscous if
the fluid is like some light kind of oil
or something the viscosity is low it
takes very little force to start sliding
one plate on top of the other if the
fluid is something like syrup that's
very goopy
then the um then it takes a lot of force
and that means that the fluid has high
viscosity
so there are these different parameters
there's the rate of flow
there's the um
the size of the object there's the
viscosity of the fluid there's also the
density of the fluid how much the mass
the fluid has per unit volume
so those are four parameters and those
are the parameters that determine
kind of the pattern of flow in a fluid
now it turns out that in the end you're
going to say this is a
that you can characterize the flow by
just a number so what you have to do is
you have to form a number out of these
parameters so out of out of something
which has dimensions of velocity
something with dimensions of length some
of the dimensions of viscosity
and dimensions of uh of of density and
it turns out that there is a
a single combination of those things
that
involves um
uh that
is
the um the object that is a
dimensionless object it's just a number
so i think it is it's called the
reynolds number
and let me think how do i work this out
i think it is
[Music]
uh that's right it's length times
velocity
divided by
viscosity times density i think
maybe the viscosity and density appeared
differently let's see i could probably
work that i think viscosity has
dimensions of mass length to the minus
one time to minus one
so that probably means okay so that
means that the density has to be it has
to be that's right it must be length
times velocity divided by viscosity over
over density
um so okay what does this formula mean
this is a dimensionless number that
characterizes the pattern of flow you'll
get so notice that it has length times
velocity so if the thing you're looking
at is bigger
the fluid flow is a certain velocity
you can that you can sort of trade off
you can have a smaller thing but faster
fluid flow and you'll get the same
pattern of flow so long as the product
length times velocity is kept the same
so what one can do then is to
characterize these different kinds of
flow in terms of the value of the
reynolds number
so i mentioned that for example at very
low flow rates i said but what i really
should have said is low reynolds numbers
the flow is laminar so a low reynolds
number might be around the number of 1
10 for something 0.1
um when the length times the velocity
divided by these other things is less
than a tenth you'll just see nice smooth
flow
as the reynolds number gets up to be
oh i don't know one or so you'll start
seeing those eddies formed behind the
object
um by the time the rounds number is like
10 you'll start seeing vortex streets
and so on you'll have a nicely developed
vortex street by the time the round's
number is a hundred or so you'll start
to get more randomness and turbulence
but what's the reynolds number for a
typical kind of thing the reynolds
number for an airplane flying through
the air is about 10 million
the reynolds number for a
car driving is
maybe a thousand i'm not sure
the reynolds number for you just running
your finger through water might be of
order one
um so they're these different different
kinds of things that go at different
speeds in different fluids
air has a much lower viscosity than
water for example
um but
in the end the thing that sort of tells
you what kind of flow will you get is
this number that is these combination of
parameters the relevance number
okay so the basic sort of fact of fluid
mechanics is that low reynolds number
you get smooth laminar flow at higher
reynolds numbers you get turbulence
and as the rounds number goes up and up
and up all you see is more and more
turbulence
more and more kind of randomness in the
flow so when you have a waterfall or
something that's a very turbulent flow
that's at high reynolds number
the um
there is actually one other number that
characterizes fluid flows which is the
mach number well actually several others
if you include other effects but if
you're just dealing with a fluid and
you're not dealing with the temperature
of the fluid and things like this the
one other parameter is the mach number
the mach number is the ratio of the
speed of the fluid to the speed of sound
in the fluid so for example for air the
speed of sound is around 330 meters per
second that's in standards of sea level
and so on that's about 600 and something
miles per hour
and what characterizes when you look at
flow past an object
the if the flow is
at a
if the object is moving
at a very small fraction of the speed of
sound then the reynolds number is all
you need to know what the flow is going
to look like if it goes close to the
speed of sound or even above the speed
of sound the mach number is important um
the uh
as you as you get to higher mach numbers
you go by the speed of sound you start
seeing shock fronts be formed and things
like that but that's irrelevant for
thinking about things like turbulence
turbulence is a story of of flow below
the speed of sound i mean it happens
turbulence also happens above the speed
of sound although it works differently
but turbulence is a phenomenon that
happens uh where the transition to
turbulence happens at reynolds numbers
of around maybe 100 or something
okay so what is turbulence
well
what happens in fluid flow
so
when you have a fluid
the
what's happening is
there is the fluid has some momentum the
pieces of the fluid
well okay we can look at it at the level
of the molecules from which the fluid is
made
if you looked in a powerful enough
microscope in water or something you
just see a bunch of molecules bouncing
around
the what happens in the actual flow of
water
is that all those molecules sort of
randomly bounce around and the net
result is that a little packet of fluid
for example will have some average speed
going in some direction we'll have some
average velocity
so then what happens is you have a
little region of fluid that has some
average velocity it's tending to move in
this direction
that means that that fluid has some
momentum it has some
uh it will tend to keep going in that
direction
the thing that prevents it from going is
viscosity viscosity is like the analog
of friction for a liquid or a fluid it's
the thing that takes motion and kind of
damps it out and just turns it into heat
when you are dealing with solids for
example you try and sort of you try and
push something uh
over the ground and
you're pushing it and it is there is a
force of friction that tends to push
against you pushing the object and
what's happening is the the energy that
you're putting in to push that object
that isn't succeeding in pushing the
object that energy is being dissipated
as heat associated with friction of the
object and it's the same thing with
fluids when there's motion in a fluid
that motion will be dissipated as a
result not a friction but a viscosity
and that motion will eventually turn
into heat so what that means is you are
pushing on this piece of fluid and
there's there's a
for a while that whole region of fluid
will move but eventually viscosity will
kind of damp out that motion will stop
that piece of fluid moving and will turn
that that collective motion of lots of
molecules into the individual motions of
individual molecules which we view as
being heat the random motion of these
molecules is is heat
so viscosity takes it damps out large
scale motions of a fluid so we and and
turns what was large-scale motion of
molecules into the small-scale motion
that is heat
so one thing that happens in a fluid is
there's conservation momentum but then
there's damping of motion as a result of
viscosity so there are really these two
different kinds of things going on in a
fluid there are sort of things that
having to do with momentum and and
keeping momentum and things having to do
with the the frictional forces the
damping momentum
so
those have uh uh
usually two names the inertial process
of sort of associated with inertia with
the tendency of a fluid that's moving to
just keep on moving that sort of
inertial effects
the other is dissipative effects taking
the motion of the fluid and dissipating
it into heat
so a lot of the story of fluid mechanics
is a competition between these two
phenomena of inertial
uh effects and dissipative effects in
fact the reynolds number this thing i
told you characterizes the kind of type
of flow is essentially a ratio of the
sort of amount of inertial stuff going
on in a fluid divided by the amount of
dissipative stuff going on in a fluid so
what that's telling you is when the when
the reynolds number is higher when the
inertial stuff is more important the
sort of motions of the fluid all around
are important compared to the effect of
damping out motion and that's when the
when the motions are important that's
when the motion can get wild and
turbulent
okay so in a fluid
there are some kinds of motions that
kind of survive longer than others for
example eddies vortices survive are one
of the types of motion in a fluid that
tends to survive
so what is a vortex a vortex is just a
fluid going around in a circle
and that's what happens in a hurricane
for example is a giant example of a
fluid vortex
and the the what tends to happen is that
the the processes that kind of the
processes of viscosity and so on that
damp out motion they have a much harder
time getting rid of that circular motion
than they do getting rid of linear
motion
it is a consequence of essentially
topology it's like you're it's as if the
fluid is kind of winding itself around
the center it's winding itself around
the eye of the hurricane and that motion
it's very hard to continuously deform
the motion of the fluid from something
that's winding itself around this kind
of hole in the middle to something which
is just not moving at all whereas if you
have linear motion it's much easier to
slow down the linear motion and the
linear motion disappears when you have
this kind of circular motion that has
this sort of topological hole in the
middle type thing
it's harder to dissipate that and so
vortices tend to be a kind of long
surviving feature of fluid motion
in general one can think of the
structure of a fluid in turbulence for
example when the fluid is doing very
complicated things if you look at it in
a small scale you'll see a whole bunch
of these little eddies of fluid just
going around the ladies
okay so in turbulence
one of the big effects is a thing called
the eddy cascade
and what happens is roughly in in
turbulent flow you'll have a sort of the
the big motion of the fluid the oh the
fluid is going around this obstacle that
sort of creates a big eddy as the thing
that sort of an eddy that's the size of
the obstacle it turns out to be a
feature of fluid flow not completely
well understood from first principles
but uh it's an empirical fact about
fluid flow the big eddies turn into
smaller eddies
and so what starts as a big idea
eventually grinds up into smaller and
smaller eddies and eventually those
eddies get so small
that
okay so you can compute the effective
reynolds number for an eddy which
depends on essentially the size of the
eddy the characteristic length of the
eddy when the eddies get small enough
eventually viscosity starts taking over
and the eddy's dissipated
but so the story of a lot of turbulence
is a big eddy is produced by the
large-scale sort of constraint on the
flow like you're going to flow around
this obstacle and then that eddy that
sort of large scale gets broken up into
in a cascade of smaller and smaller and
smaller scale ids
okay that that um that cascade is often
called the komogorov cascade after a
russian mathematician named andre
kolmogorov
who did lots of interesting things
particularly around sort of the
application of statistical ideas
to other kinds of fields like like
information theory and like physics
so
this cascade of big eddies turns and
smaller eddies as i say this is
primarily
a an empirical observation an important
fact about that eddie cascade is that
that same kind of dimensional analysis
of just saying what units appear in what
formulas and so on actually tells you
that the cascade of eddies has a very
definite form it's k to the minus five
thirds it the the if k is the
essentially the size of an eddy the
chance of having an idea of a certain
size
falls off according to a power law like
that
and there are many power laws that show
up in many places uh
um
uh you know uh
fractals are kind of a
a characteristic sort of pattern of of
of thing that you see when you have
those kinds of power laws that relate to
geometrical objects and that sort of
gives you a characterization of kind of
what it looks like if you look inside a
fluid it's kind of a little bit like a
random fractal where there is this power
law uh distribution of sizes of eddies
so anyway the the sort of the overall
picture of empirical um
uh
fluid mechanics
is this you know when you're going to
get turbulence you get a big eddy it
gets ground up into smaller and smaller
eddies the positions of all those eddies
are kind of random and eventually when
the eddies get small enough they get
dissipated into heat and uh the the and
the the turbulence isn't isn't there
anymore
but so this idea that sort of eddie's
breakdown as a smaller eddies that tends
to be true in an ordinary fluid in three
dimensions
in two dimensions it's probably not true
in two dimensions actually kind of the
opposite may happen in two dimensions it
may be that that a small eddy can
actually build up into larger eddies and
in fact that's what probably happens in
things like the great red spot at
jupiter because the atmosphere of
jupiter is well
this is a little bit unconvincing but it
is
roughly it exists in a thin layer like
the atmosphere of the earth there's a
thin layer on top of the earth but in
jupiter maybe one can think of it as
being sort of thin layers of fluid and
so what's happening is there that
something like the red spot is forming
from lots of eddies coming together to
form this big eddy that has lasted for a
few hundred years it's a giant storm
it's a giant hurricane-like storm um in
the atmosphere of jupiter that you know
was seen by galileo and is still seen by
us today but probably won't be seen for
forever more so to speak it will
eventually be dissipated um just like
hurricanes on the earth that dissipated
just like fluid vortices everywhere get
dissipated by by viscous processes but
the the tendency to go sort of
the tendency to break a big area into
the smaller eddy seems to be a feature
of three-dimensional fluids and it sort
of goes more or less the opposite way
and two-dimensional fluids maybe
um i i say maybe it's a slightly
complicated story and pieces of it are
not well understood um i remember
uh there's a lot of things one could do
with soap films where one is seeing some
of the effects of the development of of
uh of turbulence in a soap film it's a
very sort of two-dimensional thing it's
very very thin soap film um and you can
see nice effects when you see for
example when you see the sort of uh the
all the newton's fringes of of um of of
um uh all of these um in a thin soap
film you'll see all these nice colors
that come because of the interference of
light um in between the two sides of the
soap film um and you can kind of see the
motion of the soap fluid um in that in
those patterns of um in those
interference patterns
um and uh that allows you to see some
fluid motion in in soap films rather
nicely and for example the description
that i gave of uh flow around an
obstacle producing this vortex street
and so on you absolutely see that in two
dimensions but the way that those things
build up into sort of larger scale
structures and produce turbulence is a
bit different
okay so anyway that's the sort of
empirical story of fluid turbulence
and when you look at um
oh
things okay so so for example when when
people talk about aeroplanes and you
know oh fastening of seat belts we may
be heading into some turbulence
what does that mean
well the surface of the earth the
atmosphere of the earth is uh is a it's
a fluid and it is there's motion in the
fluid that motion is what we normally
call wind um and some of the time the
wind will be flowing very smoothly over
parts of the earth
sometimes the wind will be will have
will produce turbulent flow um in the in
the atmosphere of the earth so for
example behind a mountain as the air
flows over the mountain you might get
sort of turbulence behind the mountain
as in the atmosphere of the earth as you
get different heating and cooling of the
air that will produce motion in the air
that's something not included in the
most basic kind of fluid mechanics this
idea of heating and cooling of fluids
there's a sort of a
next level of fluid mechanics but that's
what causes a bunch of large scale
motion in the earth's atmosphere and
you'll see different kinds of um
different kinds of motion associated
with that so for example and there's
also motion associated with the the
rotation of the earth pretty has forces
on on fluids in the earth's atmosphere
and that produces other kinds of motion
so when you talk about turbulence
in uh for airplanes the the kind that
there's for example with a cloud a cloud
is where it is because that's where the
water vapor has is sort of uh that
that's where there is sort of a
the the upswelling of air coming below
the cloud that's pushing the the sort of
the cloud up and kind of the the force
that's pushing the cloud down is an
equilibrium and uh you you basically you
have these winds effectively below
clouds for example for thunder clouds
you have very strong winds and there are
very strong winds that that um uh that
basically pull air from the bottom of a
thunder cloud up to the top of the front
cloud so if you like fly a small plane
it's like very bad idea to go to the
base of a thundercloud because your
plane can get pulled up in the interior
of the thundercloud up to you know 50
000 feet or something um through the
core of the thundercloud because there's
this very strong wind that blows upwards
inside that but so there's one kind of
flow of
sort of rapid fluid flow that happens
around clouds um particularly i think
cumulus clouds
and um
that
that rapid flow
can lead to turbulence there's also
what's called clear air turbulence which
is the more common kind that people are
like fasten your seat belts the plane is
going to be bumping around but you
couldn't tell that it's going to be
bumping around because there wasn't any
cloud in sight
that can happen for example the jet
stream that is uh um
a uh
at certain latitudes
that that's a a kind of characteristic
wind that is as a result of the rotation
of the earth
um and that can produce uh this kind of
turbulence so in general when an
airplane is kind of bumping through
turbulence you can ask how big are the
bumps well this karmagraph cascade that
i mentioned to you this k to the minus
five thirds law that actually tells you
how big the bumps are and i don't know
completely how accurate that is but i
think it's a decent model and so what
that basically tells you the is there's
a much higher probability for a smaller
bump than there is for a bigger bump
and that means for example when you try
and make you try and design an airplane
you say how strong do the wings have to
be is it possible that there'll be a
giant eddy where the plane will just
drop 300 feet
because there's effectively you know
there's almost a vacuum in in the
atmosphere at that point
well that's unbelievably unlikely
because of the structure of this
commodore of cascade i think airplanes
can drop like a hundred feet or
something
um and uh and you know their wings are
set up so that they'll they'll they'll
still be just fine they'll kind of flap
a bit but otherwise be fine
um the uh
and that that's kind of an estimate that
you give based on this kind of this
these rules about how turbulence works
by the way i might mention that
for an ocean surface
uh it's a little bit different it's not
quite the same dynamics as as motion in
in the bulk in air um there's a thing uh
i think it's called the piss and
muscovite spectrum um which is another
kind of power law
uh thing that describes kind of the
height of waves so when you're trying to
work out you know you have um uh the um
um
um
when you have um kind of um
um
when you're designing your boat and
you're saying i want to make sure that
it has big enough you know
hulls and things that it's not going to
um uh
uh that it's not going to or it has
enough stabilization that's not going to
make everybody seasick you say up to
you know what's the probability that you
get waves of this height and so on and
that's that's given by that spectrum and
that's a a similar kind of thing to this
cascade of uh uh for food turbulence
okay so anyway that that's a little bit
of the empirical story of fluid
turbulence
and the fact that
um
you'll get these kind of um this kind of
cascade of eddies and things like that
okay so now we can ask a more
fundamental question which is how can we
explain why is there this randomness in
fluid flow it's a question i've been
interested in for a long time
so there are some theories about this i
think i know what the answer is in the
end
but let me explain what a little bit
about the theories of this
so
when you describe a fluid
there are some equations partial
differential equations called the
navier-stokes equations developed in the
early 1800s
that are a description of how the fluid
will flow
so those equations
tell you they say they have
dv by dt
where v is the velocity t is the time
they're talking about um the rate of
change of velocity
is proportional to something that has to
do with
the um
it has a term v dot grad v which is a um
which is a term that is associated with
if you look at the change of a velocity
with position
and
how that compares to velocity itself
that's another piece of those equations
there's a piece that involves uh the
viscosity
and the i mean technically laplacian of
the velocity field which is essentially
giving you
um kind of the
the um
well that that's associated with viscous
damping so anyway there's this equation
it's it's basically got three terms four
terms if you include pressure um in the
equation and it's a nasty equation
it's an equation that's really hard to
solve
so
when you try and solve it algebraically
there are very small number of solutions
that people know so for example a very
early uh success of that equation was if
you have a sphere
and you're dropping the sphere through a
fluid the question is how much drag is
there on the sphere
and there's a thing that's usually
called stoke stokes's formula and when
the when the fluid flow is is is slow it
has low reynolds number there's a very
nice
six pi
eta
av i think um
the eta is the viscosity um the um i
think the the formula is just has a
little six pi in it and it has um the
viscosity and has the radius of the
sphere and the velocity and that tells
you that simple algebraic formula gives
you the kind of the drag on the sphere
the amount of force that the fluid will
will push back as the sphere tries to
move through it that works at low
reynolds numbers as the reynolds numbers
increase
then that formula has a much more
complicated form and it's only known at
the point where you're just starting to
develop those eddies behind the sphere
that i mentioned earlier
there's still a formula that's known but
it's pretty complicated and as the flow
gets more complicated nobody has any
idea what that is like and there
probably isn't a standard formula
written down in terms of standard
mathematical functions for what happens
and what happens is complicated but you
can think of it as oh we've got these
equations
gosh that tells us everything about how
fluids work let's just solve the
equations then we'll know everything
so then a big question would be if we're
just solving the equations can it be the
case that the solutions to these
equations involve all this random stuff
that is characteristic of turbulence can
those equations support apparently
random solutions
nobody really knows
it's complicated
okay so
there are a few things that are known
so for low reynolds numbers you can for
very very low reynolds numbers you can
find nice solutions to these equations
um
the okay so a couple of things to say
so
when you look at these equations
and
you ask a question like let's say we had
a solution to these equations and we
make a small change of small
perturbation in the fluid we just change
the flow velocity a tiny bit how much
effect will that have on the solution to
the equations so that's in a sense how
how how stable or unstable is the fluid
flow
if we make if we kind of put our finger
in the flow and yeah you know there's a
little effect from our finger but
nothing big and and the flow eventually
has exactly the same form as it had
before that's a kind of stable version
of the flow if we put our finger in the
flow and putting our finger there just
changes everything that's an unstable
flow
okay so is fluid flow stable or unstable
at low reynolds number it's stable a low
reynolds number you put your finger in
there the effect of your finger will be
only quite local and the the fluid
velocity will be damped out the effect
you've had will be damped out by
viscosity you'll kind of see no sign of
your finger
as you flow go as
the fluid flow progresses at high
reynolds number the story is potentially
different can we figure out what the
story is
okay so in 1963 i think ed laurence
uh did the following thing he was
interested in in flow in the earth's
atmosphere what he did was he took the
navier-stokes equations these fancy
differential equations that represent
fluid flow and he made what's
mathematically called a modal truncation
of these equations what he effectively
did was he said let's just think of
these equations in terms of
a small number of eddies let's just
imagine that these equations are that
the solutions the equations are just
described in terms of roughly let's say
three eddies
i'm i'm i'm kind of i'm a lighting a
bunch of stuff these are actually
fourier modes and that's not quite the
same as decomposition in eddie's but
doesn't really matter basically it's
saying let's assume that the fluid flow
is governed by these particular forms
okay so then you got much simpler
equations now called the lorentz
equations
and he said well what let's try solving
these equations these equations are now
ordinary differential equations that's
somewhat simpler to deal with
and what he found is that a small change
of the initial conditions those
equations so if you just change the
initial velocity just a tiny bit you can
have a very large effect on the later
velocity that the flu the equations will
imply so what that suggests that turned
into kind of people talking about the
butterfly effect so to speak if a
butterfly flaps its wings that's a small
perturbation on a fluid in lorenzo's
equations a small flapping of the wings
a small change of velocity could have a
big effect later on in the solution to
the equations and describing the
velocities
okay so that's so in fact that
phenomenon of a small change can have a
big effect it's something that have been
thought about people been known about
actually since the mid-1800s in
different forms but there are different
places where that's important so for
example i'll give you another example
let's say you have two spheres two balls
and you bounce the two balls up against
each other okay they bounce let's say
the balls are exactly aligned on axis
then when they bounce the two pieces
that bounce are are just flat against
each other and the balls will just back
bounce back the way they came but let's
imagine that the balls are hit a tiny
tiny bit off center they hit a little
bit off center
then the ball that that the ball will
bounce they'll bounce further they won't
come back directly the way they came
they'll bounce at some angle if you make
these balls bounce again and they've
kind of moved a bit off center then the
next time around they'll hit even
further off center and so they'll bounce
even further off center so what will
happen is every time the balls kind of
go back and forth they will be uh sort
of
they'll let's say double the distance
off center that they are that they hit
each other you can do the same thing
with with light if you have a mirror
that's um uh that's a a convex mirror
and you have kind of light bouncing back
and forth between let's say convex
mirrors the thing if the if the light
hits right on axis of these two convex
mirrors great it'll bounce back and
forth but as soon as it's off axis the
it'll get sort of exponentially more off
axis it might double the amount off axis
that it is every time it goes back and
forth and so that's a kind of
amplification phenomenon that a small
change in the initial conditions a small
change in where the light was originally
bouncing whether it's just a tiny tiny
bit off axis will have a large change in
the in the in the overall motion
so that phenomenon got called sort of
the chaos phenomenon um and uh that tour
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions
the phenomenon happens even in pretty
simple mathematical systems let me give
you an example
so let's say
that you just take a number call it x
and you double it
okay but let's say you don't consider
the actual double number you just take
the fractional part of the number
so let's say i have the number
um
uh
you know
1.7 or something
uh and i or 0.7 i double it i'm going to
get 1.4 when i double it but i'm only
going to keep the fractional parts i'm
only going to keep the 0.4
okay actually let me let me make this
simpler uh let me just say i multiply it
by 10 every time instead of doubling it
so i multiply by 10 every time this
number so that means i start off with
let's say 0.45
at the next step i i i multiply by 10.
so that becomes 4.5 but i only keep the
0.5 then so 0.45 turns into 0.5 let's
say let's say the original number i had
was 0.12345
okay
that would be the initial number i
multiply it by 10 i get 1.2345 but i cut
off the one i keep only the fractional
part so i get 0.2345
i do the same thing again i get .345 etc
so effectively what i'm doing is every
time i multiply by 10 and take the
fractional part i'm like excavating
another digit down in the number okay so
let's say i'm trying to figure out
what's going to happen after a thousand
steps
well i will excavate it to the
thousandth digit in this number
so if i want to know what's going to
happen if i say this is a process i'm
i'm thinking about it as something like
light bouncing back and forth that could
be modeled with something very much like
this is often called an iterated map um
the the um
and this
this this iterated map is just you apply
the same function over and over again
and the function is multiply by 10 and
take the fractional part
so what that function will succeed in
doing is taking the the sequence of
digits
that was whatever number you gave
initially and at every step it'll
excavate another digital it'll make put
to the front the next level digit in
this number so if you say well i want to
know what happens after a thousand steps
you've got to know a thousand digits of
that number
so that means that if you wanted to
predict if you have a system it's light
waves it's something else you want to
predict what the system does after a
thousand steps you have to know
incredibly accurately what the initial
condition was what the initial number
was the initial position of the light
ray or whatever it was was in order to
know what will happen after that amount
of time and that is the essence of the
sensory dependence on initial conditions
phenomenon this chaos phenomenon chaos
theory phenomenon and that's the effect
that ed lawrence found in lawrence
equations back in 1963 or so
that
in
this simplification of the equations of
fluid flow just a small change in the
initial conditions would be amplified in
exactly this way that i described of
excavating digits could be amplified and
would just keep on getting amplified
that was what his model said
okay so that led people to say oh my
gosh
the reason there's randomness in fluid
flow
is because we're excavating these
initial digits we're excavating you know
we have this initial velocity of the
fluid and since we don't know it exactly
we sort of can assume it's kind of
random and then the reason the flow is
random is because we're excavating all
the digits of the initial conditions
this is actually a very weird theory
because it's basically saying
that
well first of all when we're excavating
digits like that we're saying what is
the precise velocity of the fluid to a
thousand digits of precision
well it's pretty meaningless because by
the time we're a thousand digits of
precision we're at a tiny fraction of
the size of a molecule of the fluid and
in fact when we want to get that precise
about a fluid we have to be microscoping
down to look at individual molecules
so in a sense what one's saying when one
says if one says that the effect that
the behavior of a fluid depends on these
very very detailed features of the
initial conditions when saying it's not
good enough to just know the kind of
mathematical description of the fluid
velocity you actually have to dig all
the way down to the molecules and see at
the level of the sort of thousandth
digit of precision what's going on so
that means that these equations that
describe fluid flow aren't actually
valid we have to actually know about the
molecules to be able to describe that
so that's that's one possible thing that
might happen in in fluid dynamics is
that the effect of just individual
things happening at the level of
molecules are being amplified and maybe
one theory is that the reason we see
randomness in fluid flow in turbulence
is that we are essentially seeing an
amplified version of the randomness of
all those little molecules bouncing
around at a microscopic level in the
fluid that is a possible theory that is
kind of the chaos theory idea about
where the randomness and fluid
turbulence comes from
i think this idea is not correct
uh basically what happens in a real
fluid
is that most small perturbations are
damped by viscosity that's what
viscosity does
how come ed lawrence didn't see that
well because the simplification he made
of the navy stokes equations does not
include viscosity
it includes only it kind of only sort of
backs into including a little bit of the
effect of viscosity if you do the same
thing he did but you keep more terms
more eddies effectively you stop seeing
the effect
it's um so in a real fluid the most of
the time i think you will not see this
effect of sensitive dependence on
initial conditions in that way
now it can be the case
that the fluid is kind of on a knife
edge the fluid could either flow this
way or flow that way and it's very
sensitive which way it will flow
in that very rare circumstance the
butterfly that comes along and flaps in
one direction or the other might tip the
fluid from going this way to going that
way but i think that's an incredibly
rare phenomenon i think the most generic
thing is that most butterflies i'm sorry
butterflies don't have a huge effect on
the future history of the world
that is they um uh you know it's not the
case
that most uh you know most things about
fluids are determined by those
microscopic things
now
having said that there is another effect
there are some other pieces to this that
relate to weather forecasting and that
have to do with how accurately you need
to know the kind of velocity of the
velocity of the of fluids to be able to
accurately forecast the weather for some
amount of time this there is a an effect
that's sort of related to this chaos
theory thing that limits that is the
thing that limits the time that you can
make weather forecasting predictions for
and so on
but i think that's the more important
effect in turbulence is a quite
different effect
the more important effect is that
something that i kind of
you know really i suppose discovered
although there were precursors of it
that were known but not really
recognized for a long time beforehand
that i kind of discovered in the early
1980s is that when you're dealing with
programs it's very common for even a
very simple program that you say this is
a simple program it's just gonna do
simple things but that program when you
actually run it will do very complicated
things in fact it will often do things
that look completely random when if you
really to analyze it you'd say oh it's
all made by the program but when you
just look at the thing it produced it's
like oh that just looks random
so a typical example from mathematics of
the same phenomenon is the digits of pi
there's a there's a way to compute the
digits of pi
you know you can know that they're the
ratio of the circumference to diameter
of a circle but there's a mathematical
procedure for generating those digits
yet once you generate the 3.1415926
etc that sequence of digit looks
digits looks for all practical purposes
random
now they did they're not random because
of sensitive dependence on any initial
conditions they're random because of
this phenomenon that
simple programs simple processes can
generate apparently random things that's
related to this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility that i've
spent lots of time investigating it's a
very core feature of what happens in
sort of the computational universe of
programs
i think it's the main thing that happens
in fluid turbulence too i think that
what's actually happening in fluid
turbulence is that the now these
navier-stokes equations
when you kind of uh what they're doing
is the equivalent of computing digits of
pi
so they're doing things where just by
running those equations you are
essentially intrinsically generating
something which is complicated enough
that it seems random to us
and i think that's where the randomness
and turbulence comes from one feature of
that claim is that it suggests that okay
so if turbulence if the randomness of
turbulence came from amplification of
molecular motions
then if you run the same experiment
twice
you won't get the same pattern of
turbulent flow because the second time
you run it you won't have the exact same
configuration of molecules and so on so
the experiment won't be repeatable
you'll get a different pattern of flow
on the other hand if what's happening is
that it's effectively the flow process
is computing digits of something like pi
it's not exactly the digits of pi it'll
be some other kind of computation but
it's just doing a computation this
result happens to look random then it
can be the case that running it a second
time you might get the same result
so you might ask what actually happens
in practice
and i've long been curious about this
and in fact there are experiments done
in liquid helium
um very well controlled experiments
about fluid flow which appear to show
long time like multi-hour
complicated patterns of flow that are
repeatable between different runs of the
experiment
however as of at least 20 or what was it
25 years ago or something now when i
talk to people who study these things
they were like
well we've seen this if you really ask
us we have seen this we don't understand
it it's so weird we don't think we can
publish it because people would make fun
of us because it's just so weird
i think in truth
it's actually a core
part of what's going on in fluid
turbulence is this kind of essentially
computational process that is repeatable
not always precisely repeatable because
there'll be differences that are sort of
hard to reproduce in the actual
configuration of the fluid when you set
it up but that sort of computational
process is the core of what's happening
in fluid turbulence
and you know that that idea has a lot of
consequences so for example if you want
to use a fluid to do a computation
that suggests you might be able to do it
you might be able to just set up the
initial conditions for the fluid and
just say okay fluid you know do your
thing and the result will be that the
fluid will compute something that is the
that might be the thing that you
usefully wanted to compute but you're
using the fact that the fluid can do a
computation
um that is also the reason that it can
produce apparent randomness you're using
it for some purpose that you want so
that's an example of something you could
do as a result of that
but
what's happened so i mean sort of the
bigger picture i would say in fluid
turbulence it remains a bit of a mystery
why fluids show apparent randomness and
their flow i think the answer is it's
from this sort of intrinsic
computational process
but that's not a uh it's not been fully
nailed down now one thing people ask is
oh for example the there's this million
dollar prize that um
got put up the millennium clay
millennium prize uh one of one of the
collection but one of them is for
showing what's the existence and
uniqueness of the navi stokes equations
so what does that mean so the
navier-stokes equations that i mentioned
are these equations that describe flow
of fluid
and the question is if you've solved
those equations
do they actually have a unique answer in
other words if you set up it could be
the case
that
you
say i want to solve these equations i've
got this particular set of initial fluid
velocities and i'm going to then figure
out what will be the result of that
fluid flow and it could be the case that
the equations stick their tongue out
back at you and say sorry can't give you
a unique answer to that
um that's one possibility the other
possibility is that the equations could
say
what that initial configuration that you
put in
causes a fluid velocity that goes to
infinity
that happens in for example the einstein
equations for general relativity
for the structure of space time you can
get these singularities that form
we don't know if similar singularities
can form in the fluid equations so what
that would what that would mean is
you've got these fluid equations and
you're saying okay
i've set up this configuration of fluid
flows and somehow the fluid will pile
itself up in some weird way and pretty
soon there'll be a piece of fluid that's
going at infinite velocity very weird
very embarrassing
we don't know whether that can happen
according to the equations of fluid flow
it would be kind of a sign that the
equations of fluid flow aren't the whole
story of a fluid because well actual
fluids don't have infinite velocity you
don't have infinite density things like
that
you might also ask given these fluid
equations what happens if you just solve
them on a computer well on a computer
when you're outside the domain where you
can do kind of analytical algebraic
solutions what you have to do is
something where you're taking this this
food this description of a fluid in
terms of this
continuous velocity field where you say
there's a certain velocity at every
position in the fluid
and you're breaking it down you're
saying actually i want to just break
that little pieces where i say this
little packet of packet of fluid that
has this velocity another packet that
has this you might use finite element
methods and you might say you're
breaking this fluid down there's all
these little finite elements that are
kind of like uh sort of little triangles
of fluid that um all sort of mesh
together with other triangles and so on
and then what you do is then you've
turned the solving of this fluid
equation which is a continuous calculus
type equation into something that
involves like like this the like all
these discrete pieces and seeing how
they fit together
well needless to say that's an
approximation you're not solving the
original precise continuous
calculus-like equations you're solving
this numerical approximation and there's
a question of does that numerical
approximation work and in particular
when you see turbulence
are you seeing randomness in the fluid
or in your computational fluid are you
seeing randomness because something went
wrong with your scheme or are you seeing
randomness because there's some
intrinsic randomness in the equations
it's really hard to tell which of those
you're seeing
now actually sometime in the 1980s i
developed a method for for studying
fluid mechanics which instead of going
from the fluid equations down into the
sort of discretized thing you can deal
with on a computer i said let's look at
the at something that is an idealization
of the molecules from which the fluid is
made and go up from the molecules so i
had a cellular automaton model of these
molecules in which there's just a grid
of possible positions for the molecules
and there are discrete molecules and
they can go at discrete velocities and
so on and what happens is as a result of
essentially the phenomena of
thermodynamics it doesn't matter
but it's a fundamental fact that
the the details of the molecules that
make up a fluid do not affect the
equations of fluid flow other than in
the parameters like viscosity so the
navi stokes equations their form of
those equations is the same for air and
for water the viscosity is different the
density is different but the form of the
equations is the same and so my idea was
take the molecules and make them
incredibly idealized and simple and
you'll still get the same uh sort of
large scale form for the fluid equations
and that works rather nicely and
it over there many technical details and
all sorts of all sorts of uh
mathematical complexity the whole thing
but basically you can go up from sort of
the underlying uh some idealization of
the underlying molecules now when you
make that under the
underlying idealization you can have
something where i uh one of the issues
when that whole thing that i mentioned
about sensory dependence on initial
conditions is a phenomenon of picking
real numbers picking numbers that can
have any number of digits you can then
you know knowing precise numbers is very
hard because numbers can have infinite
you know infinite variations as you look
at all these digits
if you're looking at a cellular
automaton where you just have these
discrete objects there is no such issue
it's either a one or a zero more or less
not it could be a point seven two five
eight four six four et cetera et cetera
et cetera so you don't have any of those
issues so you can much more precisely
ask questions like given an initial
configuration um is it the case that
the um
uh what um
can you go from some simple
configuration of molecules to for
example a more complicated configuration
yes that will often happen and could you
go from a configuration of molecules
that represents a fairly simple uh
pattern that you know represents the
flow of the fluid and potentially shows
you the emergence of sort of apparent
randomness at the level of the fluid
flow and how does that relate to the
randomness of the individual molecules
so i studied this a bit in the 1980s and
yes indeed it seems to be the case that
the randomness that you get in fluid
flow is a kind of computational
randomness of the kind that i mentioned
related digits to pi
not a sensitive dependence on initial
conditions uh kind of randomness and you
can kind of tell that in this scheme for
doing fluid mechanics
it's hard to tell from the equations
themselves you have to just do math and
calculus and things to work on the
equations if you're doing the thing i
mentioned you can use a computer to kind
of simulate what happens with the
equations so there are many many
questions about fluid turbines very
interesting questions i mean a question
of sort of how much computation can
fluid turbulence do
that relates to questions about is it
decidable is it even
is there if you say i want to precisely
know what happens in this fluid flow
maybe there is no finite computation no
computation that a computer can do in
anything less than infinite time that
will answer the question of what happens
in this fluid flow that seems to be a
likely possibility and that's sort of
almost inevitable if sort of fluid
dynamics and fluid turbulence can do
computation in some sense you might say
that the existence of fluid turbulence
is a sign that fluids do do serious
computation
if they didn't then the flow would tend
to look simple and we'd be able to say
the answer is going to be this but
actually the flow looks really
complicated and that's kind of a sign
that to know what the flow is going to
be we have to do a bunch of computation
and we could say and then the fluid
itself is doing computation and so in a
sense we could say and i hadn't really
thought of it this way but but um we
could say that the existence of fluid
turbulence
is an in-your-face sign
that
phenomena like fluid dynamics
show computational sophistication that
there is the possibility of
sophisticated computation going on even
in a fluid flow and that there are many
many examples of fluid flows i mean
another one is splashes they're a good
example of somewhat repeatable patterns
of flow etc etc etc anyway fluid flow is
a great uh area an example of um a lot
of kinds of issues that come up in
physics you know one of the things that
was always sort of a disappointment
about to me
was that in for a long time physicists
didn't really talk about fluid flow
people had said well we tried to analyze
fluid flow and didn't really work very
well
so let's leave it to the engineers to
actually build things that you know that
flow through fluids and the physicists
will kind of ignore it and this the
problem of turbulence was one of these
things that there was sort of an obscure
footnote saying oh well there's this
problem of turbulence and then you go on
with the physics textbook and talk about
what you can compute and that was a
piece you couldn't compute but i think
it's it's sort of a core thing that is a
sign of kind of it is a it's a flag that
physics was waving at us that said yes
there's sophisticated computation going
on in physical systems um and and for
the most part physics kind of ran away
from that idea
all right
that's um
it's a long discussion of floyd
turbulence thank you for that uh that
question
um
oh my did i yak on for a whole hour
about fluid turbulence well it's a great
subject
um
all right let's see
um
as a comment from prutz here how about
intelligent fluids that are about to
take over the world
yeah well this is one of the issues
about identifying intelligence and so on
you know the fluid motion in the
atmosphere
is a complicated sophisticated
computation just like
the motion of the little electric
currents in our brains are complicated
sophisticated computations
and it's kind of like this aphorism you
know the weather has a mind of its own
do those motions of the fluid in the
atmosphere in the earth's atmosphere
how do they compare to the kinds of
computations that happen in our brains
one of the things that has come out of
science that i've done is this thing
called the principle of computational
equivalence which kind of suggests that
at a raw level of computation they're
really equivalent
the um you know the
the the kind of the the motion of fluids
in the atmosphere and the the the kind
of the electrical activity in our brains
these are computationally equivalent
so in some sense if we say well gosh you
know
the future of the world hangs in the in
the balance of of the behavior of the
atmosphere then in a sense we're saying
yes it is true that that alien
intelligence of the weather which has a
mind of its own sort of is taking over
in some sense i mean it's a kind of a it
relates to this question of you know yes
it can be some sort of abstract
intelligence it just doesn't happen to
be human-like intelligence even though
it might be computationally just as
sophisticated as the things that are
going on in our brains
well let's see
her questions here
let me try and just do a couple of
others let's see if i can find some
shorter ones here
oh boy
um
it's a question from jack which
self-driving technology is better
imaging or lidar
oh i don't know but i can at least
describe what that story is about
so you got a car
it's trying to figure out you know it's
it's driving along it's trying to figure
out
what's in front of it can it uh is it
safe for it to drive in this direction
is it safe for it to change lanes things
like that
it has to know what's there
we humans know what's there basically by
looking at it and seeing with our eyes
and getting an idea of what the actual
positions of those cars are that we're
going to not run into and things like
this
we might use a little bit of information
from the fact that we have two eyes and
that allows us to know by comparing the
images in each eye we can see the
parallax the the difference between the
you know if you cover one eye and then
the other eye you'll see that objects
near to you seem to move as you but
between your as you as you look at them
from your left eye your right eye
objects near to you will move more as
you flip from eye to eye than objects
far away from you that phenomenon of
parallax
is the phenomenon that we use we use
part of that
we use that stereo vision to figure out
how far away things are by the time
things are a large distance away that's
not how we do it we typically do it just
by what the things look like and then we
have a bunch of heuristics that we use
to guess oh that thing is roughly such
and such size so therefore it must be
this distance away and sometimes we can
fool ourselves you know if there's the
sort of fake person who's out there
who's very small who's out there a
certain distance we might think that
they're further away than than than they
actually are because we kind of know we
think we know how big a person is and
it's not that size
now so the reconstruction of depth of
how far away things are based on just
what we see
is um
is a
is something that
we're used to doing we now have machine
learning systems that do a somewhat
reasonable job of taking an image even a
single image not not even two images and
saying guess how far away the things in
this image are clearly you can tell some
things about how far away things are
because for example one object will be
will be uh will obstruct another object
so then you know the object in front is
in front of the object it obstructs
things like that
so those are things that you can sort of
implicitly use in a machine learning
system to although the
you don't explicitly put in those rules
in a modern neural net based machine
learning system you just learn from a
bunch of examples how far away things
are so there are different ways of
figuring out how far away things are a
way that's used sort of nearby
is to paint a pattern of infrared light
that is in just in a grid and for
example a typical phone that's trying to
recognize your face will do that it will
paint a pattern of infrared light on
your face and depending if it's like
putting graph paper on on something so
you have this graph paper and it's it's
all marked off if the graph paper is
flat
then
then uh
you yeah if you if you imagine if you
imagine projecting the pattern of of
cross crossing lines that's on the graph
paper you projected on something that's
flat the lines will just cross at right
angles it'll be exactly the way you'd
expect on graph paper but imagine you
projected on something that's curved
then the lines will have different forms
because and they won't anymore across at
right angles and things like this
and for you know nearby that's a good
way to figure out the shapes of things
uh further away as a similar approach as
lidar um laser oh my gosh what does it
stand for it's kind of the analog of
radar with um with infrared light where
you're essentially having something that
uh you know a typical lidar device even
on a car you're spinning something
around and you're you're saying you're
sending out light in a particular
direction and you're seeing uh for
example how long it takes to come back
and you're figuring out from as it's
reflected from an object and you're
figuring out from that how far away the
object must be so it's a much more
direct way to work out uh how far away
things are from you rather than just
looking at a picture and deducing oh
well i'm more or less used to the fact
that oh that's a such-and-such kind of
car and i know they're really this big
so if they are that size in my image
they must be this distance away and so
on um the in lidar you're getting a much
more direct kind of precise map of the
whole three-dimensional structure
and so what's the trade-off between
these things i don't really know i mean
i think that what tends to happen is
look
the realistic fact is
this will be done with image-based
systems because unless the hardware of
lidar becomes simple and cheap enough
that it's really possible to look put a
little bubble on the top of your car not
one of these giant things on top of your
car to do the kind of the lidar um you
know to have a spinning thing with your
lidar and so on unless somebody figures
out how to avoid that it's just going to
be so much easier to just say install
some cameras and then do machine
learning type techniques to figure out
how far away things are um i think that
uh this question
of you know can you fool so lidar is
very very hard to fool i think
um image-based things you know they can
be fooled by different kinds of things
going on um you know they could be
fooled i don't know somebody might have
a a painting of a car on the side of a
giant truck that might confuse an
image-based system um you know they're
things like that they're harder to fool
but realistically they're going to be a
lot cheaper i suspect unless some
innovations happen in the hardware of
lidar and so my guess is that that's
that's the direction things will end up
going i mean i think the problem of
self-driving cars is not
so much this problem of sort of
situational awareness although that is
one of the issues but a lot of problems
like oh i don't know making decisions
about merging into traffic and you know
what are you going to do and when do you
take the risk of that other car may do a
goofy thing there's obviously a lot of
degrees of freedom here because for
example when a lot of cars on a road are
self-driving and can communicate with
each other you can do completely
different things than what you do if you
have one self-driving car in an ocean of
cars driven by those pesky humans who
might do crazy things
so and i i think one of the issues is
you know when you drive out you know
talking to people who do for example
quality assurance for self-driving cars
you ask what are some weird situations
that tests of self-driving cars get into
you know they're driving along the road
and suddenly uh you know a a you know
some weird kind of animal or or or a
pack of animals walk into the road and
start doing weird things and the car's
never seen that before or it sees some
some weird kind of device that that
goes into the road and doesn't know
whether that's actually a bird that's
just flying across the road or whether
it's something else so you know just a
lot of weird situations that humans
manage to say hey what's going on i can
decide what to do and it's much harder
to to do something sensible in those
cases so i think the problems are not so
much the um the detailed mapping
although it seems to help a lot i mean
people are very concerned about very
detailed mapping of roads and figuring
out at this point you can do exactly
this on this road and we know exactly
how this road is configured so you can
exactly move this way in that way
and it's all going to be okay
all right maybe um
ah let's see
um
see if there's one more i can try and do
that is fairly short
oh i'll try and do one more
uh this question from geek
what are finite fields and why are they
important
so this is not about agriculture it's
about mathematics
uh what is a finite field
so
normally we can think of numbers like
integers
and they're an infinite number of them
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine we just keep counting forever
but
there's a
form of
arithmetic where we say
imagine it's like numbers written around
a clock face they only go up to
to 12 and then they wrap back around to
one
that's so-called modular arithmetic
so if you take arithmetic mod three for
example you say you've got two mod three
you add one to that you go back to zero
you add another one you go to one and
you keep on kind of circulating around
you always are just
zero one two those are the only numbers
you can have and when you add to those
numbers you uh you're always just
wrapping around you're kind of wrapping
around the circle of three numbers okay
so that's that's an example of modular
arithmetic
okay so one of the questions about this
is
if you do modular arithmetic and you do
multiplication as well as addition with
addition you can just you add you add
you add and you might wrap around and if
you subtract again you'll wrap back
around the other way and all will be
good
and in particular every number will have
an inverse under addition so for example
you might have said to reverse the
effect of adding one
when you're doing arithmetic mod three
you you would say let's add minus one
but you don't have a minus one
arithmetic mod three you only have the
number zero one and two but if you work
it out adding 2 is the equivalent of
subtracting 1 mod 3. so you can say that
the inverse of 1 the inverse of of the
adding 1 is adding 2.
so you have this notion of inverses
uh
uh let's see so then the question is
what happens for multiplication
and turns out what happens is
when you're doing things
mod a prime if the number is like two or
three or five but not four
not not a number can be broken down as
two times two or something oh actually
i'm about to get myself in trouble here
yeah there's a little trickiness about
about powers of primes but let's start
off with just primes okay so modular
arithmetic mod prime has the feature
that not only is there are there
inverses to addition they're also
inverse system multiplication
and that gives you a certain kind of
thing called a finite field that is a
kind of nicely behaved mathematical
construct
okay what are finite fields good for
they are
they're well they're they're useful
because
um
well they're useful because they have
this inverse property but in particular
i'll give you an example of a place they
used
uh let's think how to describe this
um okay
so if you look at the back of a book
physical book i have a physical book
here let's see i've got a physical book
here here's a physical book on the back
of the book is a bar code okay
and um that bar code has a
has a number it says
isbn blah blah blah blah blah
isbn usually it starts with a a single
digit that
isbn is the international standard book
number it's a way of saying
uh every book
that is registered gets an isbn number
and that isbn number encodes the the
country it's published in the publisher
et cetera et cetera et cetera okay
those isbn numbers
uh somebody had the bright idea when
isbn numbers were first made up
let's make sure that they have a check
digit in them that is if somebody reads
you an isbn number of the phone and one
of the digits is wrong you should be
able to tell that one of the digits is
wrong without having to say oh can you
repeat that number okay so isbn numbers
have a check digit at the end the last
digit is a check digit and one of the
things you notice is that usually the
numbers are just 0 through 9 etc etc etc
but actually the last digit can
sometimes be an x
and that's a that's a little piece of
finite fieldism poking its head out
because what happens is the way those
check digits are computed is using
finite field arithmetic and there isn't
a finite field of of with 10 uh with
size 10 which would give you just 10
possible digits but there is one with
size 11. so that x because 11 is a prime
so that x
shows up there because it represents the
number 10 so to speak that appears in
the finite field of order of order 11
the field gf11 um
so
that's i'm not kind of really explaining
uh how finite fields are used to produce
those check digits but roughly it it
makes use of the fact that there are
these inverses and things to make well
this would take me a little bit longer
to explain but basically that so error
correcting codes is one place where
finite fields are used a whole bunch um
those seep into a lot of different kinds
of areas uh to do with sphere packing
and all sorts of things like that and
there's lots of fun to be had with
finite fields
it's much easier to describe them if it
was actually showing on a on a computer
and working with wolfram language where
we can deal with finite fields in very
nice ways um and uh and actually seeing
some of the things that happen but
that's at least some rough idea of what
a finite field is
and at least
uh one one use for finite fields
all right
um
i think we should uh
well
see do i get one more
i'm uh um
you guys ask such interesting questions
i i'm i i feel like i can um go on and
and i you know the thing to realize
is that um as i answer these questions
they really helped me understand the
things i'm talking about more clearly
and i don't think i've probably ever
given a long description of how fluid
turbulence works uh sort of off the cuff
like that before um and uh it's it's
really
it's useful to me to kind of try and
organize those thoughts in this way so i
appreciate that but i think we should
probably um uh
wrap up
for now here and i hope to be back next
week i will be traveling next week but i
think i'll be able to do this
we'll see might be a different venue um
might be more exotic
but
um
i hope to be able to do this again same
time next week
so thanks very much